fans of The Real Housewives of New
Jersey know how juicy Joe Giudice got
his nickname it was because of his girth
listen let's just put it this way he was
a man who enjoyed a good meal but now
juicy is more like skinny or slim it
really is crazy and it's all thanks to
Joe's prison transformation I'm just
gonna look at it just going in working
out a little break from everything how's
that
Joe's prison strategy paid off after
serving 41 months for bankruptcy fraud
he went from this to this losing more
than 50 pounds how a source tells us Joe
hit the prison gym twice a day and he
was forced to radically change his diet
no more huge Italian meals cooked by his
wife Teresa instead prison food the 47
year old also had to cut out booze no
big deal before he left - he was
drinking a lot he couldn't handle the
stress we couldn't help but notice how
much Joe now looks like another reality
star the situation and the sitch knows
all about prison transformations so the
new Mike yes how many pounds I lost 36
pounds in prison 36 yeah okay you so
much thinner than the last time I saw
you
yes I worked out between two to three
times per day as well as intermittent
fasting another endorsement for the
so-called prison diet Joe's wife Teresa
famous for this Real Housewives table
flip she served 11 months right before
Joe's term transformed herself placing
third in a bodybuilding competition
after her release did yoga Pilates step
class I ran the track I did my own DVD
tapes in the gym I left the weights
believe it or not working out three
times a day is tiring
[Music]
[Applause]